Hello everyone.
Welcome to the Lange focus channel.
My name is Paul.
Today I want to talk about knowing your
learning style.
Most people rely on other people or on
their materials to teach them,
but I want you to be empowered and to be
able to direct your own language
learning.
That's why today we are going to look at
your learning style and how to use it to
learn more efficiently.
Different people learn differently.
We all have a unique learning style that
is based on the type of sensory
information that we prefer.
These kinds of sensory information are
called learning modalities and there are
four of them.
Some people say three,
I'm going to say for they are visual,
auditory,
reading and writing and kinesthetic.
You can remember those learning
modalities based on the acronym Mark V,
a r k students generally have a dominant
modality,
but they do use a combination of all the
different modalities.
Some people will say,
for example,
I'm a visual learner,
but really what they mean is that I am
primarily a visual learner with some of
the other modalities as well.
There are some people who don't really
have one strongly dominant modality and
they call those people.